uh thank you so much I want to thank my
parents
um who were right there first and
foremost and
um I want to thank my team uh who works
with me every day my friends who are
everything to me no matter what's going
on in my career and everyone who's ever
hired me um Luke basan who gave me my
first job when I was 11 years old
um Mike Nichols who has been my hero and
my Champion for the past decade and now
Darren Aronofsky you are a fearless
leader a Visionary so many people helped
me prepare for this role my beautiful
love Benjamin montpierre who
choreographed the film and has now given
me my most important role of my life
also there are people on films that no
one ever talks about that are your heart
and soul every day most importantly my
my family my friends and my love thank
you so much
[Applause]